oh
mars 2014
des centaines de milliers d'hommes en
noir se déversent dans les rues de
jérusalem
ce sont des juifs ultra orthodoxes
ils prient et manifestent contre le
gouvernement qui veut les obliger à
faire le service militaire
les ultra-orthodoxes en étaient exemptés
depuis toujours
v rabat ont déjà fait de la prison pour
avoir étudié la torah nous sommes prêts
à aller en prison aussi les ultra
orthodoxes représentent aujourd'hui un
million d'habitants sur les huit
millions et demi d'israéliens et il pèse
sur toute la vie du pays
ce n'est pas leur quartier il n'habite
pas ici mais ils font ça chaque semaine
et nous on doit les supporter il
contrôle le droit de la famille le
mariage et le divorce au jeu travail
j'étudie je suis normal regardez où je
vis mais je ne peux pas voir mes enfants
pourquoi parce que je ne suis pas assez
religieuse ils deviennent des alliés
indispensables du parti au pouvoir
faisant et défaisant les coalitions
on ne fait pas pression sur les ultra
orthodoxes
nous avons des accords entre nous on n'y
touche pas c'est trop sensible
nous sommes les premiers journalistes à
être entré dans cette communauté qui
fait passer les lois de dieu avant celle
de la démocratie une menace pour tout un
pays
si l'état utilise la force
les ultra-orthodoxes utiliseront aussi
la force qui va gagner
on verra bien
l'image que nous avons d'israël c'est
celle là un pays moderne high tech avec
ses gratte ciel en bord de mer et sa
jeunesse branchée
les un autre israël un état dans l'état
lui fait face c'est celui des ultra
orthodoxes un monde en noir et blanc qui
vit comme au xviiie siècle
c'est à jérusalem que réside la majorité
des ultra orthodoxes pour commencer mon
enquête je décide de me rendre dans leur
centre historique le quartier de méa
shéarim 15000 ultra orthodoxes y vivent
parmi les plus radicaux pour entrer dans
ce quartier très fermé il faut respecter
des codes stricts
il me conseille de faire appel à une
journaliste franco israélienne qui
travaille pour un magazine ultra
orthodoxes bonjour mais de saab et
chantelle ali shante et on y va
alors si on veut vous voulez vraiment
vous immerger dans la société ultra
orthodoxes il me faudra vous relooker
parce que le t-shirt de un peu trop
décolletée le délinquant
pas question donc il va falloir faire
face aux tirs au but que les codes de
pudeur sont particulièrement strictes
pour les femmes c'est bon ben c'est
parfait eh bien vous avez tout ce qu'il
faut la longueur la juge les collants
alors un peu faux pas contre terre se
trouve une petite chemise ouais un peu
plus légère manches longues et de
t-shirts superposés pour qu'on ne voit
pas mais forment ce cas
bon je me sens un peu moins con verte la
whey sépare c'est parfait voilà un jeu
samir pas leurs cheveux
à l'entrée de méa shéarim un panneau
nous accueillent sur cette pancarte il
est écrit qu'il est interdit de rentrer
dans mes h est arrivé avec une tenue un
peu geek c'est à dire pour les femmes
élues au dessus du jouet
1 un peu excentré pour les hommes des
chartes alors on change complètement
l'ambiance soit si vous voyez vous
ressentiez vous même et c'est quelque
chose que ce qu'on avait 200 ou 300
mètres plus haut on vit plus austère
nous pénétrons un monde fermé où ne
vivent que des ultra orthodoxes
leurs tenues et leur pratique du
judaïsme sont nés dans l'europe du
xviiie siècle
chassés de leur pays d'origine par les
pogroms anti juif ils se sont installés
ici
bien avant la création de l'état
d'israël
en fait ces vêtements
vous auriez pu aussi avait une machine à
remonter le temps il ya 200 ans
ses grands parents et arrière grands
parents et ses ancêtres encore plus
éloignés portait exactement lé même
vêtement c'est une manière pour le
judaïsme ultra-orthodoxe de préserver sa
nature de préserver son authenticité de
garder les mêmes vêtements
c'est pour eux de leur point de vue
parce que l'assimilation que deux
ressembler aux juifs non religieux donc
il met un point d'honneur n'accord à
s'habiller de la même manière encore
aujourd'hui un refus de modernité qui
bannit radio télévision internet
alors pour s'informer les
ultra-orthodoxes pose des affiches sur
les murs
on sait affiche en fait qu'est-ce que ça
alors très s'est affichée pour annoncer
la mort de quelqu'un d'accord c'est pour
dire que telle ou telle personne est
décédée
ça ce sont des journaux cnam ouais en
fait ils envoient l'acceptent avoir très
exactement on peut dire ça comme ça
c'est là en même temps un journal même
temps un moyen de communication
moyen de ces petites annonces par
exemple qu'est-ce qui a écrit sur son
tableau alors là on se dit là parce
qu'il ya eu un accident terrible un
accident d'autobus terrible il ya
quelques jours en israël
dans ce quartier la présence de notre
caméra est vécue comme une agression
il y a un problème on ne filme pas dans
les quartiers ultra-orthodoxes si vous
voulez film est allé dans les quartiers
laïc dans le centre ville mais enfin
dans la rue non même dans la rue on ne
filme pas dans un quartier ultra
orthodoxe
l'homme qui nous interpelle ne nous
regarde pas pour une raison simple
nous sommes des femmes sortez d'ici
motte allez vous en sinon j'alerte tout
le quartier
c'est ce que vous voulez non pas du tout
sortez d'ici retourner dans le centre
ville mais on est dans la rue l'homme
est vite rejoint par un voisin tout
aussi énervé si vous ne partez pas je
hurle il nous escorte jusqu'à la sortie
du quartier pour nous empêcher de filmer
on est dehors je vous ai dit d'aller
dans le centre la ligue mais on est
sorti du quartier ils vont vous casser
la caméra attention
notre incursion dans le quartier de méa
shéarim n'aura duré qu'un quart d'heure
jamais une caméra n'a filmé l'intimité
des ultra orthodoxes
pendant plusieurs mois nous allons
essayer d'entrer dans cette communauté
sans succès finalement un homme accepte
de nous ouvrir ses portes
yona tan est un ultra orthodoxe désireux
de défendre son mode de vie traditionnel
marié père de famille il ne donne
rendez-vous un matin dans le centre de
jérusalem
première règle que nous découvrons c'est
le rabbin qui décide de tout dans la
société ultra orthodoxes dans notre
communauté
on ne passe pas le permis de conduire
quand on le veut il faut d'abord
demander aux rabat si on a le droit de
le passer moi la première fois que j'ai
demandé il m'a dit non tu ne peux pas le
passé et puis il m'a dit revient dans un
an on en reparlera mon frère lui a
demandé lui aussi et le rabbin lui a
aussi dit non d'ailleurs il n'a toujours
pas eu la permission de passer le permis
pourquoi aucune idée
c'est notre rabbin c'est lui qui sait
pourquoi il prend ses décisions jeu
l'ignorent si je le savais je serai
rabat sa place deuxième règle
les hommes ne doivent pas travailler
leur unique occupation prier et étudier
les textes sacrés toute la journée
comme tous les matins oyonnax thann se
rend donc dans sa yeshiva son cercle
d'études religieuses
l'ofs
un univers d'hommes uniquement ils
passent leurs journées à répéter
commenté expliqué la torah le texte
sacré juifs
l'image que tu des pins il faut bien y
penser il faut la vérifier
étant donné qu'il a choisi le chemin le
plus difficile qu'il n'a pas choisi la
facilité
on peut penser qu'il dit la vérité il
faut le croire tu ne peux pas accepter
cette réponse mais si justement
ok d'accord une virée j 24 heures sur 24
par la religion et son étude à la minute
même où je me réveille je me sens déjà
un soldat de l'armée de dieu j'ai peur
de dieu ce que dieu veut est important
pour moi je pense à dieu à chaque
instant par exemple après m'être laver
les mains m habiller je fais mon café le
matin mais je ne le vois pas directement
d'abord je prie merci dieu de m'avoir
donné du café que tout soit fait selon à
volonté et après je cours à la synagogue
pour prier
après les prières et l'étude de la torah
la valeur centrale de la vie ultra
orthodoxes c'est la famille
à 32 ans il y aune à tana quatre enfants
deux filles qui vont à l'école primaire
et deux petits garçons là en maternelle
l'autre en crèche
je sors du jour ce que ma femme a
préparé hier pour leur déjeuner bonjour
comment ça va oui même bien dieu merci
je t'ai affaires dans ta chambre
ici pas de roman ni deux journaux dans
la bibliothèque que des livres sacrés
les enfants n'ont jamais vu de consoles
de télévision ou d'ordinateur tous
proscrit alors après l'école il joue aux
cartes seul objet de modernité un
téléphone portable mais lui aussi fait
l'objet d'un contrôle vous avez un
téléphone c'est oui c'est mon téléphone
cacher validé par le rabbin si on a
vraiment besoin d'un smartphone
on peut en avoir un mais il faut
l'autorisation du rabbin moi mon rabat
me connaît bien
il m'a donné une autorisation spéciale
il a contacté la compagnie de téléphone
pour l'autoriser à m'en vendre à un
internet strictement encadrée et dont
chaque application est validée par le
rabbin
le yunnan est mariée à ryan soit béni
mon dieu pour ce repas même dans leur
vie tout est codifié même leur intimité
des contacts physiques des marques
d'affection comme se prendre dans les
bras ça on ne peut pas le faire à la
maison
en tout cas pas devant les enfants si on
veut le faire il ne faut surtout pas que
la femme et ses règles là c'est
totalement interdit de se toucher
on peut se dire des mots gentils ce
genre de choses mais pas au delà
vous ne vous embrasser pas non pas de
baiser on ne s'en lasse pas non plus
puisque les hommes passent la journée à
étudier
c'est aux femmes de travailler
raya tient un salon de perruques un
business florissant puisque toutes les
femmes ultra orthodoxes doivent se
couvrir la tête entièrement [ __ ] et
ici on préfère la perruque aux voiles
rail a elle même porte une perruque
c'est par pudeur que les femmes se
couvrent la tête
non c'est un devoir spécifiques aux
femmes qui sont mariées même une femme
qui a divorcé elle n'est plus marié mais
elle doit quand même se couvrir la tête
ce mode de vie ultra orthodoxes les
hommes en noir sont prêts à tout pour le
protéger
même s'il faut en découdre avec l'état
d'israël l'état d'israël en tant que
telle est moins important pour moi que
la torah le livre sacré alors entre
l'état et nous ont fait le nécessaire
pour que tout se passe bien mais il y a
quelques dossiers explosifs
si l'état utilise la force les
ultra-orthodoxes utiliseront aussi la
force qui va gagner
aucune idée j'espère qu'on aura jamais
besoin de vérifier qui est le plus fort
pour l'instant l'état ne fait rien pour
gêner les ultra orthodoxes
bien au contraire ceux-ci grignote petit
à petit le territoire israélien en toute
impunité
yona tan vit dans le quartier de malades
daphna avant tout le monde ici était là
y tient petit à petit il y a eu de plus
en plus d'ultra orthodoxes et
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus un seul laïque
il reste quelques pratiquants modéré il
y en a un là bas et quelques autres plus
bas mais c'est tout quand les
ultra-orthodoxes arrivent en nombre dans
un quartier laïque les laïcs quittent le
quartier aujourd'hui dans ce pays il ya
un fossé énorme entre ultra orthodoxes
et laïque
on ne peut pas être voisins voilà mon
fils
bonjour mon ange tu vas bien la société
ultra orthodoxes cherche à créer son
propre espace
une sorte de ghetto moi je me définis
comme quelqu'un d'ouvert
j'ai vu le monde j'ai même étudié à
l'université mais aujourd'hui quand je
dois aller à tel-aviv
j'ai l'impression de voyager à
l'étranger
l'israël de tel-aviv ont tout aussi
dangereux à ses yeux que les nazis
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale sinon
rabat présente aujourd'hui la situation
hors du monde ultra orthodoxes comme une
shoah spirituel ce n'est pas une shoah
dans le sens où la société israélienne
essaye de détruire le monde ultra
orthodoxes mais ce que nous voulons dire
c'est que celui qui sort du ghetto
risque de perdre le mode de ville traoré
knox résultat c'est comme la shoah une
vision du monde partagé par quasiment
toute la communauté d'oyonnax thann et
certains groupes ultra orthodoxes pousse
le raisonnement encore plus loin ils
veulent tout simplement la destruction
d'israël
ce sont les neturei karta littéralement
les gardiens de la cité
chaque année le jour de la fête
nationale
ils brûlent le drapeau d'israël
et déploie celui de la palestine heures
il n'hésite pas à serrer la main du
leader iranien ahmadinedjad qui en
appelle à rayer israël de la carte
avec ce cadeau nous vous manifestons
notre gratitude pour toute la douceur et
l'amour que vous exprimez envers les
juifs et l'humanité tout entière
ils rendent même visite à ismaël haniyéh
leader du hamas à gaza
pourtant en guerre avec israël et à
l'humoriste dieudonné accusé
d'antisémitisme en france nous sommes
invités par le leader du mouvement le
rabbin hirsch il habite méa shéarim
autour de chez lui des drapeaux
palestiniens ont peint sur les murs les
neturei karta refuse d'avoir une carte
d'identité israélienne de recevoir tout
est de cet état et ils ne déclarent pas
leurs enfants à l'état civil
pour se distinguer des autres
il parle même le yiddish un mélange
d'allemand et d'hébreu que leurs grands
parents parlaient en europe de l'est
leur idéal vivre dans un futur état
palestinien
nous refusons d'être citoyen d'un état
israélien quel qu'il soit parce que nous
savons ce qui est écrit dans le livre
sacré gea premier au peuple juif de le
sortir de l'exil
or nous sommes en exil depuis 2000 en
tant que cet exil dur il est interdit au
peuple juif de fonder un état dans
quelques parties du monde que ce soit
ici ou en ouganda
peu importe si vous voulez vraiment que
l'état d'israël devienne la palestine
bien sûr nous réclamant la justice
divine pas d'état juif sans la volonté
de dieu en attendant nous sommes en
palestine il ne peut pas y avoir deux
états pour deux peuples
ce n'est pas une bonne solution la
solution pour l'instant c'est vraiment
de rendre tout le territoire aux
palestiniens colas est
les ultra orthodoxes ne se contente pas
d'appliquer la loi de dieu chez eux ils
veulent aussi régenter les quartiers
laïque où ils n'habitent pas
nous sommes au marché du centre ville
bien loin de méa shéarim et des
quartiers ultra orthodoxes
il est 15h30 un vendredi après-midi
l'ambiance est détendue bon enfant
mais les ultra orthodoxes ont décidé de
faire fermer le marché
tous les vendredis après midi pour
préparer l'arrivée du shabbat jour de
repos hebdomadaire en israël
et pour ça ils ont une solution radicale
des coups de trompette pour forcer les
marchands à fermer leurs échoppes
allez allez il est à rentrer chez vous
chabot approche allez on se dépêche
religieuse ou laïque juifs musulmans ou
chrétiens
tous doivent tobin
paca tout acheter si tu veux que je
rentre chez moi mais tu revendre à ça
après demain ok shabbat arrivée on a le
temps ça commence dans plus d'une heure
l'homme en noir est vite rejoint par
d'autres
ils font partie d'une milice religieuse
ils ne sont pas mandatés par la police
uniquement par leur foi
si quelqu'un ferme son magasin de dix
minutes plus tard qu'est ce qui se passe
ils débarquent de leur quartier un
million de religieux débarque et il lui
shabbat
c'est déjà arrivé que quelqu'un refuse
de fermer oui ils ont foutu le bordel
ils ont crié et jeté des pierres il crée
des problèmes
si on travaille pendant le shabbat ils
deviennent fous complètement fou regarde
en voilà un autre c'est bon pas la peine
d'entrer
des clients laïque du bar du marché
assiste impuissant à la fermeture du
lieu
ce n'est pas leur quartier il n'habite
pas ici mais ils font ça chaque semaine
et nous on doit aller supporter mais ils
ont droit de faire ça la police leur en
donne le droit n'ont pas le droit mais
il joue avec les limites de la loi
il se jette sur tous les terrains sur
lesquels ils peuvent avoir de
l'intérieur excusez moi
la police nous donne le droit de leur
dire de fermer excusez moi
la police vous donne un droit de leur
dire de fermer s'il vous plaît juste une
réponse paraît pas répondre ou alors
parce que je suis une femme et
apparemment ils se sentent de leur droit
des brevets tour de fermer à la place de
la police
les hommes en noir ont réussi à fermer
toutes les boutiques avant shabbat et ce
dans un quartier laïque
une bataille de plus gagné par les ultra
orthodoxes
hahahaha
à l'été 2015 déjà là aussi dans un
quartier laïque
il s'attaquait à un cinéma encore ouvert
à jérusalem pendant shabbat
et parvenait à le faire fermer
tous les vendredis dès 15 heures
jerusalem devient ville morte
jérusalem n'est pas la seule ville visée
par les ultra orthodoxes un peu partout
en israël
ils élargissent leur territoire eli est
chauffeur de taxi il a grandi à bet
shemesh à une demi-heure de jérusalem
une ville qu'il ne reconnaît plus
lorsqu'il était enfant
vingt mille laïque vivaient ici
aujourd'hui 80 milles ultra orthodoxes
se sont accaparé la ville et sa banlieue
elie nous promène dans des quartiers
devenus entièrement ultra orthodoxes
ici les rues ne porte que des noms de
rabat
sur les murs comme amer shéarim une
pancarte oblige à respecter le code
vestimentaire ultra orthodoxes cette
fois encore nous ne sommes pas les
bienvenus
qu'est ce que vous faites là pourquoi
vous filmez c'est à moi que vous parlez
pourquoi vous ne regardez pas je vous
conseille de partir pour qui vous
travaillez
je vous demande ça parce que c'est un
quartier dangereux pour vous
pourquoi n'êtes vous pas descendu avec
moi je préfère rester dans la voiture
pourquoi parce que je suis plus chez moi
ici même pour se promener même pour me
promener j'aurais l'impression de
cautionner leur présence c'est pas chez
moi ce lieu ne m'appartient pas c'est
pas l'israël que vous connaissez c'est
par israël que je reconnais
elie nous emmène sur les hauteurs de la
ville pour nous montrer que les ultra
orthodoxes ne vont pas s'arrêter là
partout des immeubles en construction
maintenant ils construisent sur toutes
les collines environnantes
ici ce sera leur nouveau quartier
c'est le gouvernement qui leur a donné
le permis de construire ça va être
encore plus grand encore un quartier
ultra-orthodoxe encore une autre
banlieue de matthieu pêche
ce sera un quartier exclusivement ultra
orthodoxes évidemment ce sont des
quartiers dans lesquels il n'y aura
aucun laïque
autour de jérusalem
deux autres villes comme à bet shemesh
se construisent sur mesure pour les
ultra orthodoxes
retour à jérusalem dans la presse je
découvre que les ultra orthodoxes
utilise désormais d'autres moyens pour
faire pression sur les laïcs dans le
centre ville quelques commerces résiste
et refuse de fermer pendant shabbat
ils ont tous dû obtenir des dérogations
de la mairie parmi ces commerces
l'épicerie de david qui a ouvert en 1995
bonjour
cette fois pas de manifestation devant
l'épicerie les ultra-orthodoxes ont
choisi la voie politique pour parvenir à
leurs fins ils font pression directement
sur la mairie une loi qui a plus de 60
ans dit que les commerces doivent être
fermées pendant shabbat
mais depuis des décennies on avait un
accord les ultra-orthodoxes rester dans
leur quartier
nous dans le centre ville on est dérangé
pas il ne nous dérangeait pas et on
pouvait vendre aux touristes aux
étudiants tout se passait bien jusqu'à
ce qu'un jour le maire décide de faire
fermer nos magasins
désormais ces commerces ont interdiction
d'ouvrir pendant shabbat
les ultra-orthodoxes ont obtenu que le
maire actuel de jérusalem reviennent sur
les dérogations qui leur avait accordé
le maire de jérusalem s'appelle nir
barkat aussi un candidat laïc et sans
étiquette il a retourné sa veste
aujourd'hui membre du likoud le parti de
la droite au pouvoir ils marchent main
dans la main avec les ultra orthodoxes
c'est à n'y rien comprendre
c'est nous qui l avons élu on est allés
aux urnes
on a donné nos voix pour qu il nous
représente nous les habitants laïque de
jérusalem
c'est un coup de couteau dans le dos
je demande une interview du maire mais
son cabinet refuse
merci pour votre demande d'interview
malheureusement le maire ne pourra pas y
répondre
j'adore ce style
je décide donc de me rendre au marathon
de jérusalem en scéne nir barkat qui
l'organisent
il doit même y participer
c'est la télévision française
bonjour enchanté vous avez été élu en
promettant de protéger les laïcs comme
les religieux
vous avez le sentiment de le faire alors
que la ville est divisée en tant que
maire je travaille pour qu'il y est une
bonne entente entre tous les habitants
de jérusalem
je fais en sorte que chacune des
communautés de cette ville se sentent
bien mais il ya des laïcs y pense que
vous les avez trahi par exemple vous
fait fermer des épiceries dans le centre
ville ces commerçants là se sentent
trahis
mais non regardez le marathon
aujourd'hui les gens sont très heureux
ils comprennent que la ville va dans la
bonne direction concernant les épiceries
elle était dans l'illégalité
moi en tant que citoyens responsables
j'agis dans le cadre de la loi je dois
donc régler ce genre de problèmes depuis
votre élection vous donner le sentiment
de protéger les ultra orthodoxes au
détriment des laïcs
ce n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas vrai
alors qu'est ce que vous avez à dire aux
commerçants dont vous fermez les
épiceries les épiceries n'ont pas le
droit d'ouvrir pendant shabbat
c'est comme ça c'est illégal et en tant
que mère je dois respecter la loi et la
faire respecter
ok merci beaucoup vous n'avez pas le
sentiment que jérusalem est prise en
otage par les ultra orthodoxes
le maire a décidé d'aller dans le sens
des électeurs ultra-orthodoxe de sa
ville il faut dire que ces derniers
représentent aujourd'hui la moitié des
votants à jérusalem
à l'échelle du pays
les ultra orthodoxes sont un million sur
les huit millions et demi d'israéliens
ils sont aux ordres de leurs rabbins
même quand il s'agit de voter avec une
moyenne de 6 enfants par foyer il forme
un réservoir de voix de plus en plus
attrayant pour les politiques qui leur
cède du terrain
dernier exemple en date le ministère des
affaires religieuses a été confiée à un
ultra-orthodoxe david azoulay et pour la
première fois depuis longtemps son
ministère gère l'institution du mariage
et des divorces
depuis divorcé est devenu extrêmement
compliqué pour les femmes israéliennes
car dans la loi juive respecté à la
lettre par les ultra orthodoxes
seul le mari est habilité à accorder le
divorce par l'intermédiaire d'un
tribunal religieux aux rites éducatrice
spécialisée mère de dix enfants a mis
sept ans à obtenir le divorce de son
mari alors qu'il avait refait sa vie
dans votre cas les rabbins du tribunal
religieux ne vous ont pas aidés non j'ai
dû attendre de nombreuses années avant
que les rabbins n'oblige mon mari à
m'accorder le divorce
pourtant il habitait à l'étranger vivez
avec une autre femme et ne paient pas la
pension alimentaire
c'est incroyable j'étais la victime et
six mois qui étaient harcelées par les
rabbins d'audience en audience
vous ne vous en sortiez pas il n'y avait
aucune solution aujourd'hui aux rites et
au parlement pour témoigner devant une
commission face aux injustices de plus
en plus nombreuse faites aux femmes des
députés sont chargés d'évaluer le
fonctionnement des procédures de divorce
il a fallu des années avant que les
rabbins du tribunal religieux demande à
mon mari de m'accorder le divorce lors
des premières audiences
le rabbin qui présidait la session ma
culpabiliser il m'a dit vous êtes
capables pourquoi avez-vous lancé cette
procédure de divorce chez vous la
coupable chemin alors que je suis la
victime dans cette affaire
le rabbin du tribunal a fait deux mois
la responsable de tous les problèmes de
notre couple la cible de la commission
aujourd'hui le directeur des tribunaux
religieux c'est un rabbin ultra
orthodoxe
il s'appelle szymoniak au but en israël
on dit qu'on ne peut pas résoudre le
problème des divorces et le pire
c'est la vérité mais pas parce que c'est
difficile ou que vous manquez de moyens
non c'est juste parce que vous ne voulez
pas comment peut-on résoudre tous les
problèmes liés au divorce avec si peu de
moyens
franchement madame la députée vous ne
voulez pas entendre ce que j'ai à dire
je vous ai déjà tellement entendu
répéter les mêmes choses
je n'en peux plus j'ai du travail si on
attend de moi que je change la façon
dont les tribunaux religieux applique la
loi juive je ne le ferais prochain au
sein du parlement
c'est un dialogue de sourds à lisa la
vie dirige cette commission
parlementaire
pourquoi ne peut-on pas toucher au
mariage et au divorce religieux à cause
de ce gouvernement
oui c'est un gouvernement dans lequel il
y à des ultra orthodoxes
le gouvernement a passé des accords avec
eux ils leur ont dit vous nous soutenez
et on ne touchera pas à tout ce qui est
en rapport avec la religion
donc tout ce qui concerne la séparation
de la religion et de l'état est bloquée
comme les transports publics ou les
commerces ouverts pendant shabbat
on ne peut plus avancer sur ces sujets
malheureusement
je décide d'aller voir le ministre des
affaires religieuses
l'ultra orthodoxe david azoulay au
dessus de son bureau
les rabbins ultra-orthodoxes fondateur
de son parti
beaucoup de femmes disent que les
tribunaux religieux ne les soutiennent
pas bien sûr que pour les femmes le plus
facile c'est de dire que le problème
vient des tribunaux religieux mais c'est
inacceptable les tribunaux religieux
font leur travail
c'est facile de critiquer mais eux ils
agissent ça et c'est difficile pour les
femmes laïques
vous accepteriez un mariage un divorce
civile en dehors des tribunaux religieux
l'état d'israël est un pays juif mais
c'est aussi un état démocratique
democratic oui mais c'est avant tout un
état juif
un juif laïc c'est un juif du point de
vue de l'état d'israël que oui bien sûr
mais en israël il n'a pas le droit de se
marier de divorcer autrement que devant
les tribunaux religieux
un rock hard rock la loi en israël
oblige tout citoyen qui veut vivre ici
comme juif à se marier dans la religion
juive
quand on vient dans l'état juif
on vit comme un juif celui qui va en
arabie saoudite respecte l'arabie
saoudite et il doit se comporter comme
un saoudien
la différence avec l'arabie saoudite
c'est qu'israël est une démocratie pour
vous israël est un état religieux
on nous aimerions bien que ce soit un
état religieux
mais malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas
alors vous mettez une limite à la
démocratie et cette limite c'est la
religion
si seulement on pouvait mettre une
limite à la démocratie
un ministre qui rêvent de soumettre la
démocratie à la religion un rêve pour
lequel se battent deux partis politiques
fondés par les ultra orthodoxes yaadout
hatorah et le shass chasse la révolution
est en marche
deux parties aujourd'hui au gouvernement
et qui occupe 11 % des sièges du
parlement
certains décident de quitter ce monde
ultra orthodoxes ils sont environ 1300
chaque année bonjour bienvenue
aviva a quitté la communauté ultra
orthodoxe
il est à trois ans la voici lorsqu elle
en faisait encore partie sur la photo
elle a découpé l'image de son mari un
homme qu'elle n'a jamais aimé avec
lequel elle a eu six enfants six garçons
aujourd'hui ma situation est bien
meilleure sur mes vielles belle ce n'est
pas comme avant désormais je m'amuse je
souris j'étais une personne ferme et
silencieuse je faisais mon travail et
rien d'autre aujourd'hui malgré les
circonstances
j'aime la vie mais sortir de ce monde
clos un prix aviva a été puni son mari
soutenu par le tribunal religieux lui a
interdit l'accés à ses enfants
on l'accuse en des pires travers il a
dit que je prenais de la drogue qu'il
fallait m'envoyer en cure de
désintoxication
je leur ai dit fait une prise de sang
tous les examens que vous voulez si vous
trouvez une trace de drogue
je ne reverrai pas mes enfants mais si
vous n'en trouvez pas je veux les voir
évidemment ils ont refusé de faire
l'examen et il ne m'autorisent plus à
voir mes enfants
ces choses là n'arrivent que dans un
tribunal religieux dans un tribunal
normal et dans n'importe quel pays
même un meurtre ayant en prison peut
voir ses enfants aux airois les forges
thaïlandais alors vers à canet et moi je
travaille
j'étudie je suis normal regardez où je
vis mais je ne peux pas voir mes enfants
pourquoi parce que je ne suis pas assez
religieuse
les garçons avaient entre 3 et 16 ans
qu'on le divorce a été prononcé
c'était il ya trois ans et c'est la
dernière fois qu aviva a vu ses enfants
regardez comme ils sont mignons
on voit qu'ils sont heureux d'être avec
moi n'est ce pas ils ont pu passer deux
heures ici c'est la dernière fois que je
les ai vus comme aviva de plus en plus
de jeunes gens cherchent à fuir le
milieu ultra orthodoxes dans lequel ils
sont nés pour leur venir en aide
une association a été créée en 1992
quelqu'un a encore faim autour de la
table ce soir une quinzaine d'anciens
ultra-orthodoxes ce qu'on appelle les
sortants c'était un dernière soirée avec
nous oui je déménage à tel aviv
ils s'installent là bas yahouda 27 ans
est devenue laïque il y a seulement neuf
mois pourquoi vous venez ici pour les
gens peut s'asseoir se reposer manger
c'est comme ça c'est comme une vraie
maison
quitter cette communauté c'est perdre
tous ses repères pour plonger dans un
monde dont il ignore tout alors ici la
prise en charge est totale repas
logement suivi psychologique
on leur propose même des vêtements car
s'habiller reste un défi pour des gens
qui portent l'uniforme ultra-orthodoxes
noir et blanc depuis la naissance
les vêtements je n'y comprends rien
c'est vraiment un problème
je ne suis pas habitué à choisir des
vêtements
avant je portais toujours la même chose
je ne sais pas entrer dans un magasin et
commença à choisir c'est tellement ça ne
vous vient pas naturellement
non non vraiment pas je ne comprends pas
ces choses là
vous aimez les couleurs je ne sais pas
pour moi c'est presque tous pareils je
ne vois pas la différence yahouda était
un autre homme il ya seulement quelques
mois
le jour de son départ il enregistre
cette vidéo sur son téléphone portable
bonjour je m'appelle yehuda konnov nice
qui je suis né et j'ai grandi dans une
maison ultra orthodoxes je n'ai jamais
été en accord avec le mode de vie de ma
communauté
j'avais envie de m'ouvrir de connaître
autre chose et bien sûr c'était interdit
alors j'ai décidé de partir je vais me
construire une vie meilleure plus
heureuse charest et j'espère que je vais
réussir pour nous parler de son intimité
yoga nous invite chez lui
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur dans votre
nouvelle d'y trouver un appartement vous
faire à manger
non ça va je me suis habitué
le plus dur ça a été de trouver une vie
sociale mais surtout les filles ça c'est
très difficile le pire souvenir de
yehuda c'est son mariage
un mariage arrangé avec une jeune fille
qu'il ne connaissait pas non seulement
j'épouse cet inconnu mais je suis
supposé dès la première nuit coucher
avec elle un rabbin m'a expliqué comment
faire il faut que ce soit dans
l'obscurité la plus totale
la femme doit juste relever sa tunique
moi je reste allongé à côté d'elle je ne
dois pas la toucher
quand c'est possible de ne pas toucher
non non il n'y a aucun contact avec les
mains des baisers non non rien tout ça
est interdite je dois attendre que
quelque chose se passe que ça dure 6 ce
moment là c'est la femme qui doit me
faire entrer en elle moi je n'ai droit
de ne toucher à rien années je me suis
sentie vraiment mal
aujourd'hui liés ou d'apporter un regard
sans concession sur la communauté dans
laquelle il a grandi
la communauté ultra orthodoxe et très
extrémiste
donc quand on la quitte on passe dans le
camp ennemi
si j'avais grandi dans une maison
religieuse modéré je pense que je ne
serais pas parti parce que chez les
modérés on peut penser autrement sans
que ce soit un crime alors que dans ma
communauté
il est carrément interdit de penser moi
j'appelle ça une secte c'est un mode de
vie qui vous dit ne réfléchit pas à
charger
d'autres anciens ultra orthodoxes ont
décidé d'aller plus loin et attaquent
l'état d'israël en justice
cinquante trois plaignants accusent
l'état de les avoir abandonnés à ce
groupe sectaire et à une éducation
purement religieuse car les
ultra-orthodoxes délivre un enseignement
conforme à leur vision du monde dans un
réseau d'écoles parallèle où les
disciplines de base ne sont pas
enseignées
lui aussi est bas font partie des
cinquante trois plaignants je me
souviens des cours de biologie livre
avec lesquels ont étudié passé comme on
dit à la censure nos profs enlever les
passages qui parlait de choses comme la
rue production hommes femmes et tous les
autres sujets qu'on n'avait pas le droit
de connaître la seule leçon de biologie
que j'ai reçue était en conformité avec
la loi juive et en vue de mon futur
mariage le garçon n'ont même pas reçu
cet enseignement là car chez les ultra
orthodoxes
les garçons reçoivent encore moins
d'éducation que les fini leur vie
n'étant programmée que pour la prière et
l'étude des textes sacrés l'école
devrait être fait pour nous préparer à
la vie mon école ne m'a préparé qu'à
devenir un bon religieux il aurait fallu
ajouter à cet enseignement des
disciplines qui me permettent de gagner
ma vie d'être un bon citoyen aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens nous demandent pourquoi
on ne fait pas plus tôt un procès à nos
parents ce sont vos parents les
responsables pourquoi attaquer vous
l'état la réponse est simple l'état
savait qu'on nomme ans n ya rien à
l'école en revanche mes parents n'ont
pas le baccalauréat
mon père n'a pas de diplôme mon grand
père non plus ils n'ont pas conscience
de ce qui me manque mais l'état inscrit
dans la loi les bases de ce qu'un élève
doit apprendre pour être un citoyen
responsable
or moi je suis rien et cette éducation
de base
on ne me l'a pas donnée
et aussi et bars attendent beaucoup de
ce procès il espère éveiller les
consciences
les ultra orthodoxes représentent 60%
des enfants qui vont à l'école
maternelle à jérusalem il ne faut pas
oublier que ces enfants ultra-orthodoxes
vont constituer la prochaine génération
d'adultes en israël on ne peut pas les
laisser sans éducation fondamentale et
garder le silence
le premier ministre est il prêt à faire
évoluer les choses
nous voulons interroger mais binyamin
netanyahou refuse c'est la
vice-présidente du parlement
nourri de koren qui nous reçoit bonjour
on va faire vite car il faut absolument
que je vois un docteur je suis malade
pourquoi le gouvernement cautionne t-il
l'absence d'éducation des ultra
orthodoxes
quand j'étais petit j'ai étudié
justement dans une école ultra
orthodoxes il y avait la géographie et
une partie des disciplines fondamentales
mais vous êtes une femme
ce n'est pas pareil pour les garçons oui
c'est plus problématique c'est vrai ils
n'étudient que les matières sacré c'est
vrai
le gouvernement voudrait vraiment
ajouter les enseignements fondamentaux
dans les écoles ultra orthodoxes mais
ces derniers s'y opposent complètement
c'est plus difficile de faire avancer
les choses depuis qu'il y à des ultra
orthodoxes gouvernement yazid ray on ne
fait pas pression sur les ultra
orthodoxes
nous avons des accords entre nous on n'y
touche pas c'est trop sensible
là vous toucher aux questions les plus
complexes du pays on ne peut pas en
parler maintenant
d'ailleurs je n'ai même plus de voix
pour en parler comment peut-on dans un
pays démocratique comme israël passé des
accords avec des partis religieux qui
pensent que la loi religieuse est plus
importante que la démocratie
je ne peux plus parler à l'hermine
encore je dois voir un docteur
on va s'arrêter très bien merci
la question est sensible car d'ici 2050
un tiers de la population israélienne
sera ultra orthodoxes persuadé que la
loi de dieu est plus importante que
celle des hommes
israël un état menacé depuis sa création
entourée de pays ennemis finira peut
être rongé par un ennemi de l'intérieur
on